too many red pill alpha guru types take
advantage of attachment issues to score
cash from wounded men and encourage them
to embrace their attachment wounds even
further it turns into a cult of people
convinced their wounds are scare are
sacred truths
man i catch a lot of flak because people
come in at me and say that's not what
red pill is about and and they're right
it's not red pill is supposed to be
evolutionary psychology applied to
relationships so that you can be healthy
and love each other love your wife love
your husband based on biological
imperatives within men and women that's
what it's supposed to be
in effect when you become a red pill
guru to make money off of these people
you say no dude you're right women are
scum they'll never really love you
they're just there for the things you do
for them so you should just make them do
good things for you and take advantage
of those insecure women have sex with
them on the first date and never call
them again because screw them that's
what they're teaching and those guys
come in believing there's nothing better
and they hear that message and say wow
they feel like i feel but they're
turning it around i'm not the piece of
crap everybody else is the piece of crap
so it's okay the eye they owe me they
owe me this so they
go out and start using that and all that
does is create a whole society of damage
hurt women who go back and act exactly
the same and those nice guys
get hurt and then start looking for the
red pill community and say man all these
terrible things have happened it's a
self-perpetuating cycle between men and
women and that's all it is you don't
stop it until you fix the actual
problems which is not what red pill
gurus do to make money well the
equivalent to make money
the equivalent on the female side is
radical feminism right it's not
it's not as if red pill is the only root
to this there is a an equal polarity on
the other side of the fence which is man
i've i've gone on to some of the reddit
threads i can't remember what they're
called
it's not women's rights
it's not our slash women's rights but
it's one of those it might be the female
red pill or something like the other
pink pill or some [ __ ] and um you go on
there and you think
this is this is just as bad
as what you see in some of the meninism
manosphere spaces
it is it is and you know what it doesn't
have to be and my areas i mean i'm i'm
in touch with all kinds of like
masculinity coaches and all the like
cringe-worthy names that you would have
and some of them are the best men you
would ever meet who actually pull men up
out of this and say no dude fix your
behavior you're finding bad women
because you are a bad man and they make
the men fix themselves women there's
some women doing the same thing on their
side trying to fix it until you have
that fix between the balance of the
sexes and get back to our biological
imperatives and and understand what they
mean and and fix them and fix the
attachment now that's going to get
better but yeah man there's
there are grifters on both sides and
they are happy to take advantage of
those attachment issues they will take
all your money all day long and tell you
that what you're feeling is normal and
that you should embrace it and get worse
so you can pay them more man i can see
the allure of it you know this the the
in my less gracious moments when i felt
jilted or insulted or not wanted or
whatever i can see those areas of me
that would become seduced by that sort
of talking point you know you have this
hurt man
who
feels like the world has done him wrong
and
it's much easier to create a conspiracy
around an entire gender
that this is women at large as opposed
to
maybe you just chose a shitty one man or
maybe maybe you just rolled a bad hand
maybe it was unfortunate look or poor
timing or maybe
the the particular combination of
circumstances a little bit of you and a
lot of them or a lot of them and
whatever
that caused a bad situation to come out
of it and for some reason it's more
comforting to believe that this is a
uh a
pandemic at large that only affects one
half of the population
it's you know and and both sides say it
both sides feminists say every man is a
potential rapist and and men say every
woman is a potential divorce rapist
she'll take all your money
both sides do it and there's a lot of
money in it there's a lot of political
power in it both political parties are
deeply invested in these these things
and whole nations are turning on these
ideas it's not just the internet it's
it's the world right now yeah there's um
meme culture is so [ __ ] smart man i'm
sure that you'll have seen this one it's
these two dudes these two um black
illustrations of guys with beards and it
says a woman hurt me and i never made up
about it uh we should call ourselves
alpha males and then they just walk away
you think [ __ ] man like
the the main problem that i have with
the red pill space is that
almost none of the guys that are in that
space look to me like the alpha males
that i would want to follow none of them
embody the sort of actual genuine
integrity trustworthiness honor um
sensitivity uh genuine masculinity none
of the guys embody that it's just
i don't know it's the equivalent of a
girl replacing
beauty with a boob job and lip fillers
you know it's all it's all front no
substance does that make sense very much
absolutely because
the understanding red bill it's really
just evolutionary psychology that's
applied that's all it is
taking it on and saying i am a red pill
man means you have got stuck there if
you get out of a bad relationship you
should learn evolutionary psychology
about what women actually biologically
want from you and about attachment you
should learn those things red pill is
right now the only place where men can
speak these old truths that fathers
would have said to their sons like well
son let me tell you about women red pill
is the only area men can go to hear that
now because we don't have relationships
with our fathers or grandfathers or
uncles anymore we don't have male only
spaces red pill is the only area where
they can do that
so they go there and they learn these
things and the men who are good and
healthy i shouldn't say good people but
they're healthy
they move on they learn it and then they
move on into something else they learn
they move into
their church system or they move into an
honor culture with an honor tribe online
they move into masculinity groups
instead of red pill groups they move
into married men support groups where
they're building each other up good ones
um they move into fraternities and
things in programs like that they don't
get stuck and say i'm a red bill man
when you do that
that means you really are stuck and you
really need to move out of that group
it's a good on-ramp but it's not the
highway and we can replace red pill with
extreme feminism right you know and
basically get the exact same situation
have you looked at black pill or the
in-cell culture much
you know um i've worked with a lot of
them i know a lot of them not that like
in-cell's a movement but i mean i know a
lot of dudes who are in cell i know a
lot of dudes who are black pill um those
are those could be two different things
um
it hurts it hurts when they're going
through and i understand a lot of it is
built on a lot of it's built on
attachment issues not all of it but a
lot of in-sell things are built on
attachment issues and they don't
understand how or why and they do need
applied evolutionary psychology to
understand like why are women not
attracted to me well let's talk about
that let's talk about what women
biologically want and then let's talk
about the culture of things that are
also in tune and we can get you a
girlfriend man i teach courses i teach
dudes how to get girlfriends and it
works like that how to get married i had
one dude i taught him how to get married
he went from men i don't know i don't
know how to do this he got married
like three like man he got a engaged
three months after i taught him he got
engaged and he got married they've been
happily married for years now
like you can learn this and apply it and
it's not that hard
um
but the black pill stuff man and and
giving up
it hurts it hurts to see because it
doesn't have to be that way learn
attachment learn evolutionary psychology
and then find an actual tribe of quality
men that you can connect with and you
won't feel that way anymore because
you'll start building with other people
don't feel don't be alone anymore clear
all the obstacles out of the way from
being that make you feel alone
or if you don't know how to do that talk
to somebody that's the other piece men
our brains are solution machines and we
can only pump out solutions with data we
already have if you don't have the data
you got to talk to another man who has
solved the problem get the data from him
and he'll give you that data and you
build a solution that's how our brains
work our brains men's brains we're like
the internet we're supposed to share
solutions and if you don't yeah you're
going to get stuck
what it made me realize thinking about
red pill and black pill is i had nama
katson who did a ton of research into
the in cell community and in these black
pill communities which are basically
nihilism for anyone that doesn't
understand it it's kind of like
relationship nihilism for men typically
and
what she said was that anybody that
suggests any small hint of ascending
which would be a girl in a coffee shop
smiled at me today it's not even going
for a date or i got a girl's number it's
any tiny little sliver of attention from
the female gender
that as soon as you do that as soon as
you show in any of these forums these
black pill forums that you may have had
a little bit of
attention as soon as you show that
that's you out you're ostracized from
the group and the reason for that is
that it gives undue the subtext for the
reason for that is it gives undue hope
to the other people in that group well
if this guy has managed it then maybe so
am i and it's i
how would you say
it's a loyalty it's a show of loyalty
that you're not prepared to try and
ascend right it is a um a sacrifice for
the group look i'm putting the interests
of the group over the interests of my
own happiness and i think in red pill
it's almost the same
that it's a um a commitment to
seeing women as a means to an end to
committing to this particular narrative
around them being gold diggers or being
able to move from man to man very very
quickly dude like
the world that these guys exist in
seems very very detached from mine i've
spent a lot of time around a lot of
girls all of whom are in that single
party girl mode who are about to move
into becoming someone that wants to get
married and settle down and have kids a
man like when those girls find the guy
they everything gets switched off i've
seen the biggest [ __ ] that have worked
for us
that had just a different guy every
night of the week they'd be moving
between different parties different
groups and then as soon as they find
someone that they care about that mode
just gets killed i'm like this this this
isn't the case but
when you're in a community of an echo
chamber of that and you're probably not
spending a whole lot of time in the real
world to disprove these ideas
that's all that you can see
and you know what most of those women in
that party mode are there because it's
attachment issues they're there because
that's all they know that's all they
know how to feel good and get attention
they're using sex to get love most women
i mean those are the visible women
that's the problem those are the visible
women you know where most women are
they're at home they're families they're
watching tv they're knitting they're
they're coloring they're playing video
games they're petting their cat they're
sitting with their family and having a
good time that's where most women are
and you will not be introduced to those
good women because the people you know
are going to look at you as a disaster
not you but i mean red pill dudes and
black pill dudes
other women and your family and friends
aren't going to say hey you should meet
this wonderful woman i know who's like
22
she's never ever had a boyfriend she's
just sweet and she just wants to be a
mom
they're not going to say hey dude you're
like smoking pot you don't have a job
all you do is yell and complain about
women and you're trying to bang all
these women in the club i should
introduce you to this great young woman
i know yeah no that's not how the game
works man so you're only going to see
these visible women at the club you're
like she's sleeping with somebody every
night why not me why am i the only man
in town she hasn't slept with you know
that's not a great place to be
um but yeah man when women when women
know they know when when women see you
and they see that your value they attach
to you with claws and they will never
ever let go and they will sleep outside
on your front porch until you open the
door when a woman really loves you
that's how far they go um and i know
this because i've been with my wife like
14 years and if i tried to walk out the
door she would handcuff me to her like
it is what it is women know
and when they get in good relationships
they start to heal they instinctively
build self-correcting networks a healthy
woman instinctively builds
self-correcting networks
they just do
especially once they have children then
they really start building
self-correcting networks suddenly
attachment problems that you both had in
the beginning of the relationship are
now a problem and she starts looking at
you as the threat to the kids because
the kids aren't building good attachment
with you that's where a lot of divorces
come in when women become moms most
women
they want to fix their attachment issues
but they don't know how and now they're
angry at you for having attachment
issues yeah i mean fix your attachment
issues it doesn't happen this came up in
the first episode where you said that a
lot of issues that women have in
marriages where there's kids isn't
necessarily to do with their
relationship with the father it's the
father's relationship with the children
that the woman is now being very
protective over the kid's life and she
sees that the man is not being the
father that she wanted
and that causes a defense mechanism to
kick in which actually creates friction
between man and woman
that's what i tell men when when your
kids are like 10 years old or 12 years
old or even teens and she's going at you
and it looks like she wants to kill you
and she's mentioning divorce
there is no way on earth you can fix
your relationship with her unless you
fix your relationships with your kids
first and if you fix your relationships
with your kids first that automatically
just about fixes the relationship with
her because all of a sudden all the
problems she had with you
is now great and the kids are talking
about how great you are and she sees you
with them and her oxytocin starts
flowing or dopamine every time she looks
at you and the kids and they are
laughing and hugging you and smiling her
brain automatically makes her like you
more because you are good for those kids
that's this is this is what red pill
should be teaching this is applied
evolutionary psychology it's all it is
her brain releases dopamine oxytocin
vasopressin all kinds all kinds of
bonding chemicals when she sees you
with the kids and the kids are happy to
be with you if you can fix that
man that's like it's like putting your
marriage on easy mode if you put if you
if your relationship with your kids is
rocky or distant and the kids are
nervous and anxious all the time man
you're putting your marriage on hard
mode then it's good luck getting a smile
out of her that would be a man's
manosphere movement that i would totally
totally get behind if it was more to do
with okay how do we make a marriage as
sick as possible like how do we make a
marriage as awesome as easy as possible
because you know
end of the day that's kind of what men
would like we've still got other [ __ ]
that we want to try and do
you know the goals in the gym or the
sport team that we play on a weekend or
the bike that we're obsessively fixing
when we get home from work
being able to do okay how do i make the
marriage is as easy and comfortable and
also because you care about the partner
and so on and so forth yeah man that
would be someone someone out there
should create
a branch off of red pill that is
about married men becoming better
married men and the same the same for
women as well you know understanding
evolutionary psychology and not just
this
tribal hatred what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you